hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my Game of Thrones episode 9 video
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen it yet far and away the strongest
episode of the season so far this is the
only episode that HBO has submitted for
multiple Emmys like writing directing so
before this ever air like after HBO saw
the final cut of it they decided that
this was probably the strongest episode
of the season not to say that the finale
won't be amazing but a lot of times you
find like the craziest episode comes
right before the finale speaking of
which the finale next week is going to
be 69 minutes so because there's so many
other storylines to wrap-up that's
probably why the episode is 15 minutes
longer next week so just be aware and
adjust your DVRs if you do record this
but a lot of awesome callbacks to
previous episodes this is a lot like
Watchers on the wall Blackwater episodes
that are consumed with a big battle even
if they have a few other things going on
and I think they made the right call and
choosing just Daenerys his storyline and
Jon Snow's northern Battle of Winterfell
storylines to go with I like the way
that they're matching them to up it's
almost like they're getting ready for a
big reveal of some kind next week so top
10 WTF and I'll explain book moments as
we go along so number 10 the other two
dragons finally get out as predicted
finally it's about time you see a giant
fleet roll up you have two weapons of
mass destruction locked up makes sense
that you would let them out to play so
we finally get to see the three dragons
in battle just a preview of the words to
come think about what this scene is
going to look like when they make it to
Westeros number nine goes hand in hand
with Theon and Yara showing up they have
the ships they make a pact
Daenerys even bonds with Yara over their
terrible fathers this is a really big
deal a number eight WTF the Iron Islands
will become independent again that was
part of the terms of the agreement you
give us the Iron Islands back and we
will find a new cultural heritage that
does not involve reaving and raping so
it sounds like if everything goes well
the Iron Islands will just become
merchants they have the most powerful
fleet in the world it would make sense
that they would just make money off of
that instead of piracy but not before
Daenerys helps her kill a few uncles
that don't think women have the right to
rule so you could look at this as a sly
wink at the uncles the Greyjoy uncles
the show did not do like Victarion for
instance but no surprise that Daenerys
is reaction to your on I think that was
one of the easiest predictions of the
season you're on just like grabbing his
crotch air
humping daenerys just saying all the
things he's gonna do to her just like
Ramsey would he's kind of like Ramsey in
that moment so when Daenerys hears that
she chuckles a little bit like why would
I ever make a pact with this kind of
person so it is very believable that she
sides with Yara but not without a price
the nurse is like you have to help me
take Westeros and stop doing all of the
things you've been doing for thousands
and thousands of years it becomes
another one of those burning down the
old ways moment they've had that several
times this season where it's like
there's this old way of thinking versus
the new way of thinking but one thing at
a time
first they have to get to Westeros and
she has to figure out how she's going to
take the Iron Throne is it going to be
by force will there be another war or
something else going to happen that's
why Tyrion in the teaser for the next
episode said now you're in the great
game as if the real battle is just to
come and obviously we're thinking about
the war for the dawn but that's even
further down the road first she's
thinking about Westeros and the Iron
Throne she hasn't even mentioned White
Walkers once so as awesome as we got
victories in both these storylines for
Daenerys and for the Starks is really
just the beginning number six Jon Snow
offers Ramsay the easy way out of the
fight so they're just treating Jon
explains he's only taunting him Liyana
Mormon is there with her awesome sass
phase I was so happy that they let her
be in this scene she wrote up like a
badass even though there is the threat
of death but you just get a whole lot of
Ramsay swagger
he calls Jon Snow a bastard several
times it's almost like every time he
opens his mouth he says bastard at least
once but I did like that the writers let
Sansa be the one to shut him down just
like she did at the end of the episode
this is almost more sonses fight than it
is Jon's John is fighting the physical
battle but for Sansa the context is so
much greater given what happened to her
at the hands of Ramsay during season
five but sauce is the one that's really
moving the game pieces around like she's
just learning to play the game of
Thrones a little finger style just like
Daenerys is so number six was actually
all that battle planning in the
conversation that he had with Sansa
after so he comes off as this really
smart person these are the traps we're
going to lay for Ramsay this is how
we're going to lure him in but then
Sansa comes along and is like you don't
know Ramsay like I know him he doesn't
fall for traps he lays them for people
please don't do what he wants you to do
which of course he proceeds to do in the
battle so number five at the battle
field Ramsey releases Rickon do you like
playing games little man in his tragic
his richens death is even if you didn't
read spoilers about this episode you
could have read the cues in the way they
filmed this in the musical score that
they put to it it was such a tragic
scene and Ramsey was stone cold with the
bow like he was missing on purpose until
he finally hit Rickon we know from Theon
storyline in season 3 that Ramsey or
maybe it was season 4 that Ramsey is a
good Archer the minute he picked the bow
up and he was shooting a tricking I just
thought of them chasing down that girl
like he was literally hunting a girl
like a wild animal
there were a lot of visual callbacks to
previous episodes like this so number 4
Davos finds the wooden stag that he gave
to Shireen there was actually this scene
of her that's so heartbreaking where
she's playing with it just like a little
girl would play with her toys and you
just see over the course of the rest of
the episode like by the end he just has
murder on his face I was surprised that
he didn't kill her at the end of this
episode but they will follow up on it in
the next episode you can imagine how the
conversations going to go what kind of a
God would ask you to do these terrible
things that was a lot of what that
conversation that Jon Snow had with
Melisandre was all about like how do you
know what the hell's going on does this
mean anything is there even a god but
you have to remember Ian McShane
character where he's like it's all the
same to me that was actually a really
important conversation maybe this idea
of God isn't as important as the idea
that everything is connected like it's
this magical weave this power of nature
that everybody shares so there will be
some heavy-handed religious themes in
next week's episode as you would expect
because they have the trial of the faith
so a whole lot of religion happening in
episode 10 from the red God to the faith
of the seven number three is just the
amazing battle choreography it was one
of the biggest episodes they've ever
filmed for Game of Thrones they said
it's one of the most expensive two just
because it's really expensive to have
all those people all the horses in the
time they took to film it was longer
than normal episode so they have to pay
all the crew so as episodes get bigger
and more epic like this the cost grows
exponentially so you understand how
they're talking about doing fewer
episodes next season because there's a
little bit less story for them to tell
in the episodes are more like this big
and crazy with a lot of CG and a lot
more dragons so everything the
cinematography just so beautiful and the
way they weave music in Jon so it's
almost like Jon
so getting buried under the bodies is
him dying again and then clawing his way
back to life like he clawed his way back
to life in Episode two
so really awesome call back to that
moment if I die don't bring me back I
order you not to bring me back but in
this moment it's like he's choosing for
himself and he claws his way back to
life
Wolverine style how crazy was that giant
pile of bodies I was so worried when
they dropped the teaser that this was
one one which is a couple people on top
of him but note that is just a giant
pile of bodies so number two of course
Jon Snow vs. Ramsay you offered a
one-on-one fight I'd like to take you up
on that so Jon Snow gets revenge for all
the terrible things that Ramsay's done
just starts beating the [ __ ] out of him
for killing one one but he stops when
Sansa walks up and I think the reason
that he stopped he didn't finish killing
Ramsay is because he sees himself in her
eyes and he doesn't want to become
Ramsay himself he doesn't want to turn
into the monster that Ramsay is so when
walking away it's a nice mirror for
Sansa walking away from Ramsay after
telling him you're nothing no one's
gonna remember you no one is going to
remember your house it was a little more
satisfying once anza did it because of
the context between those two characters
but there was also a moment like that
with Jon Snow and Ramsay when Jon Snow
walks away from him but number one of
course such a juicy treat they do not
deny us the pleasure of watching Ramsay
being eaten by his own hounds they were
loyal until you starve them which is a
nice metaphor for the way he treats
people in what a real leader is like
Daenerys for instance or at least tries
to so this ties back to the old ways
versus the new ways the old ways would
have been the Ramsay way to just rule
with an iron fist be like the Mad King
Sansa Jon Snow Daenerys
those characters represent the new way
they did an amazing job
mirroring those two final moments the
deaths of the Masters with the death of
Ramsay as in the death of the old ways
so this is real push-pull between old
ways new ways especially with the King's
Landing storyline because Cersei is
really like our protagonist we're seeing
a lot of this from her perspective but
the reversal that's different from the
other storylines is that Cersei is kind
of the villain in that storyline even
though the show isn't necessarily
painting her like an antagonist she's
just fighting to keep what's hers and
what a coincidence that Tyrion even
name-dropped the hidden wildfire all
over King's Landing so we're talking
about burning down the old
ways to make way for the new so I just
love the way of Cersei emerging as the
clear front-runner for big villain but
she's such a good villain because she's
just fighting to hang on to what is hers
fighting to hold on to her family we'll
have so much Cersei and Jaime stuff to
talk about next week I might dedicate a
bonus video to why Cersei is the best
villain and Game of Thrones right now if
the show is telling us that the old ways
are getting burned down there must be a
new way what does that say about Cersei
storyline even though she's gonna come
across with a big victory will come out
seeming like a big villain so let me
know in the comments what was your
favorite part of the episode you know
even it was just something minor like
seeing Ramsay getting eaten by his own
hounds but was it not the best episode
of the season so far
I mean we haven't seen the finale yet
but you can watch this ten times in a
row and just be completely hypnotized by
how amazing it looks how the story plays
out in the music the music is such an
important part of Game of Thrones that I
don't really talk about that much but
like at the end of the Aria episode last
week they had this great music track I
had to extract is that I can listen to
it on soundcloud there's so much awesome
stuff happening so there will be bonus
videos this week I'll be doing a QA be
sure to subscribe to get all that stuff
there's also a new round of the giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I've just done a video kind of
explaining how bastards work on Game of
Thrones so I'll put a link in the
description for those of you that are
asking Gendry could totally become king
bastards can become kings under certain
circumstances William the Conqueror was
one of the most famous bastards in real
life who became king so Jon Snow for
instance even if he's still a bastard if
he is the son of a Targaryen he could
also become king but while you guys wait
for my next video to post you can click
here to learn all about bastards on Game
of Thrones even the ones that can become
kings and you can click here for last
week's episode 8 video thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you